спершу тренування стрільби що
підтримувати навички і перебуваючи на
відстані від лінії фронту
потім пауза поповнення запасів і трохи
відпочинку
Інтернаціональний Легіон був у складі
Української армії від самого початку
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії
ми просто підрозділ звичайний підрозділ
просто іноземці і ми разом з українцями
Макс ебергард мав дворічний досвід
служби в німецькій армії і приїхав в
Україну вже за кілька тижнів після
початку війни Я ніколи не думав що в
Європі знову може бути війна і я справді
не мав важливіших справ хіба що нудна
робота я хотів допомогти людям із
зеленськи теж закликав тому я приїхав
сюди
на початку війни Зеленський звернувся як
він сказав до друзів миру та демократію
щоб вони допомогли захистити Україну це
вразило фінського добровольця з позивним
Гобіт
ної
мені здавалося що Європа зробила
недостатньо і я пам'ятаю коли у нас була
війна у нас були добровольці тож я
подумав Принаймні я можу це зробити
губіт має на увазі радянсько-фінську
війну 1930-х років багато хто з них
згадує історичний досвід своїх країн
добровольці з понад 60 країн взяли в
руки зброю на боці України
це налаштованість по суті на готовність
до рішучої боротьби за західні країни це
стратегічний рівень на тактичному ж
рівні на рівні поля бою більше нюансів
деякій підрозділи і працюють на другій
лінії тому що вони не здатні виконувати
справді складні завдання і їм довелося
зазнати великих втрат якісь підрозділи
дуже ефективні Але їх не так вже й
багато Лише кілька тисяч Тож вони не
дуже відрізняються один від одного Але я
вважаю що головний вплив полягає в тому
щоб на стратегічному рівні зберігати
настрій на протистояння агресії
дехто тут лише на кілька тижнів або
місяці вони воюють пліч-о-пліччя з
українцями але іноземні бійці можуть
піти і повернутися додому якщо захочуть
і ця різниця має суттєве значення каже
Кале бліц
коли ви в українському підрозділі то
помічаєте що там усе чисто У них є люди
які готують і все організовують і це
приємно тому коли ви повертаєтеся з
завдання усе бездоганно чистим але з
легіоном оскільки він новий Там завжди є
нові люди люди йдуть і повертаються тому
продовжують робити ті самі помилки тож
місця іноді брудні не так добре
організовані вони не прибирають після
себе
калеп ліс з Австралії він не мав
військового досвіду коли прийшов рік
тому але зараз вже командир взводу каже
що збирався вступити до Французького
іноземного легіону коли Росія вдерлася в
Україну але змінив плани
пошук пригод за його словами був
частиною мотивації
я хотів себе перевірити я хотів
приєднатися до Французького іноземного
легіону тому що хотів відчути
екстремальну ситуацію тож я прийшов сюди
з тієї ж мотивацією і зрештою зробив це
і зараз я займаюся тим тому що це єдине
У чому я справді гарний
цей Легіон не можна порівнювати з
французькими іноземними легіоном Так
звичайно це підрозділ які повністю
складається з іноземців але ці іноземці
воюють в Україні і за Україну якщо вже
на те пішло Вони борються не за Францію
Німеччину Великобританію США Канада чи
Грузію Грузія До речі зробила істотний
внесок у Легіон вони воюють за Україну
це знають усі зокрема й Росія НАТО в
цьому взагалі не бере участі насправді
навіть не в курсі чуток про причетність
НАТО до легіону Це просто Пропаганда
тут далеко від фронту все трохи
спокійніше Легіон воював під українським
командуванням на бахмутському напрямку
та під час Харківської наступальної
операції
у губі та також є і свій напів
жартівливий опис їхнього найважливішого
внеску у війну
[музика]
гинути або бути пораненим кожні пару
місяців щоб Україна продовжувала бути у
заголовках газет і захід продовжував
надавати підтримку Я маю на увазі що ми
не збираємося цього робити але я думаю
що врешті-решт Це виявиться найбільшим
внеском які ми можемо зробити
Якщо припустити що вони не зроблять
такого внеску усі троє чоловіків кажуть
що не планують повертатися до
нормального цивільного життя